T
PRIVILEGE THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
WILL HEAR A MAJOR ABORTION
RIGHTS CASE NEXT FALL.
THE DECISION COULD HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT AND EFFECT ON HISTORIC
ROE V. WADE RULING.
CORRESPONDENT DAVID SPUNT HAS
DETAILS TONIGHT FROM THE SUPREME
COURT.
[CHANTING]
>> FIVE DECADES AFTER THE
LANDMARK ROE V. WADE DECISION
ABORTION RIGHTS COULD SOON BE
ROLLED BACK SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE COURT AGREED TO WEIGH IN ON
A MISSISSIPPI LAW THAT WOULD BAN
THE PROCEDURE AFTER THE 15-WEEK
MARK.
BEFORE VIABILITY WHEN A FETUS
CAN SURVIVE OUTSIDE THE WOMB.
>> THIS IS A BLATANT ATTACK ON
ROE V. WADE.
THIS IS A 50 YEAR PRECEDENT
COMING OUT OF A SUPREME COURT
THAT HAS LAID DOWN THE LAW AND,
YET, WE CONTINUE TO SEE AN
INCREASE IN ATTACKS ON ROE.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE RESPONDED TO
THE NEWS WITH A PRESIDENTIAL
PLEDGE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS COMMITTED TO
CODIFYING ROE REGARDLESS OF THE
OUTCOME IN THIS CASE.
>> ORAL ARGUMENTS ARE SCHEDULED
FOR THE FALL.
BLOCKED ENFORCEMENT OF SIMILAR
LAWS CITING ROE'S PRECEDENT.
>> WHEN YOU DRAW DOWN ON THIS
PUBLIC OPINION WOULD BE VERY
FAVORABLE TOWARD THIS
COMPASSIONATE LAW GOING BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT.
>> LAST AUGUST JOHN ROBERTS
SIDED WITH THE LIBERAL WING
STRIKING DOWN RESTRICTIONS IN
LOUISIANA.
HE JOINED RUTH BADER GINSBURG
THE STRONGEST CHAMPION OF
ABORTION RIGHTS.
>> SOLEMNLY SWEAR.
>> GINSBURG'S REPLACEMENT AMY
CONEY BARRETT DEVOUT CATHOLIC
WHO IN PERSONAL LIFE HAS MADE
CLEAR ANTI-ABORTION STANCE,
THOUGH PUBLICLY SHE SAID HER
PERSONAL FEELS WON'T MIX WITH
WORK.
THIS CASE SIGNALS HOT BUTTON
ISSUES ARE WELCOME AT THE COURT.
THE JUSTICES WILL SOON HEAR
CASES ON GUN CONTROL AND
EXECUTIVE POWER, AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION AND IMMIGRATION
CHALLENGES MAY SOON FOLLOW.
>> THEY ARE STARTING TO GATHER
MOMENTUM AND THE VERY VERY
CONSERVATIVE MAJORITY ON THE
COURT IS, I THINK, HEADED IN THE
DIRECTION OF AN ABSOLUTELY
BLOCKBUSTER TERM NEXT YEAR.
>> THE COURT LIKELY WON'T MAKE A
FINAL DECISION ON THIS CASE
UNTIL ABOUT A YEAR FROM NOW.
PRO-LIFE AMERICANS ARE FEELING
CONFIDENT, BRET, BECAUSE THREE
JUSTICES APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
TRUMP CURRENTLY SIT ON THE